Morning, Retsuko.
Oh, hi, Fenneko.
It's morning and I'm tired already.
I just ran into Tsunoda downstairs.
Tsunoda...
I hate that girl.
Really?
I'm not fond of her, either.
I'm following her online, though.
Based on my analysis,
there's a pattern here.
A pattern?
She uploads photos
as if she's an idol.
Take a look.
Selfie, dessert, latte art.
Selfie, dessert. Selfie, dessert.
Selfie, selfie, her bare thighs.
She posts a thigh pic
once every 13 days, without fail.
I'll say it again.
-Selfie, dessert, latte art. Selfie--
-Yeah, I get it.
It's not the drink she's showing off here.
It's her thighs.
You see?
She posted a picture
of her legs again on Saturday -
three days earlier
than her usual pattern.
She must have found a man
she wanted to show this to.
I highly suspect
it was at Friday's office party.
Oh, good morning, Fenneko!
Good morning.
Hey, did you get your nails done?
Oh! That's right!
I went to a new place.
Wow. They look really good.